what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible and no the
title is not a spoiler that's literally
what the volume is called
invincible volume 18 the death of
everyone it just happens to be a really
clickbait volume so here's the thing
about this uh what we initially do here
and there's a little bit we're kind of
skipping over just because of the fact
that we got a lot to unpack over the
course of this this video so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna pick up
basically with the uh coalition of
planets prison which of course is
orbiting telescope and that's where omni
man nolan is currently being held right
keep in mind that nolan basically stood
to alan the alien and tried to stop him
from basically showing up to earth with
the scourge virus and then obliterating
the whole thing now of course because of
the actions of both nolan and mark allen
the alien basically sending the entirety
of the scourge virus around the earth
was basically halted right that was
essentially stopped but because of this
and because of everything going on the
fact that basically nolan and mark were
right but ultimately nolan's being let
go right all the charges against him
were being dropped and he's basically
being freed here now a lot of this seems
to come from allen because alan kind of
looks around and it was like i was set
on all sides as being the coalition
leader i was caught up in my role i felt
like i had to do something that sort of
thing so really taking a brunt of this
on himself and ultimately letting alan
go the other thing about this is
remember mark lost his powers but that
does not stop adam e from wanting some
of that nightly loving you know what i
mean like you know that's a power he
hasn't lost
[Laughter]
mark is not in need of viagra and so
where he's a little hesitant about it
right because there you know when it
came to their personal life you know
this kind of intimacy element it seemed
like his power sort of added something a
little extra to it and without that he
basically seems to be lacking and so as
a result of this he's like no we're good
but in the middle of them basically you
know doing the damn thing and getting it
on suddenly marcus he starts freaking
out right and the reason why is because
he's levitating so there you have it
guys if you want to have powers go have
sex so here's the thing about this
in all reality once mark's powers
essentially snap back and he's back to
really being in his role as invincible
one of the first things he does is he
goes and he sees dinosaurs right now the
big thing about this is that dinosaurs
didn't know if mark was ever able going
to get his powers back right if mark's
ability to go back to being invincible
was ever going to return and the funny
thing about this is that dinosaur is
kind of looking at the superhero
landscape and looking at the roles the
superhero play really saw mark is a cut
above the rest so the reason why is
because mark was one of the only people
who consistently challenged cecil right
that when you had the new iteration of
the guardians of the globe who took over
the version that were basically killed
by nolan back before he left earth and
all that kind of good stuff that they
don't really question cecil more so than
that they're part and parcel to humanity
and that while mark does see himself as
being part of humanity mark was also the
one that to a degree seemed to show some
leniency to dinosaurs in the sense that
he rescued him and then also said like
your idea of trying to find ways to
improve humanity is a good thing but the
truth is that what you're trying to do
here is causing problems that ultimately
without mark being there dinosaurs
didn't really see a way for humanity to
basically fix itself specifically with
regards to the environment right the
humanity was just going to keep on
making things worse until it got to a
point where humanity realized how bad
they'd screwed things up and then by
that point it would just be too late now
some people would look at that and say
okay but like humanity made its own bed
humanity should lay in it humanity
should basically push the brink of
extinction if it doesn't die out then
hopefully those who survive will make
better choices and if it does die out
then it was basically the entire human
race putting a gun to its head and
pulling the trigger right like humanity
did it to itself and so the results of
this is that with mark gone he was like
okay something needs to be done here and
so what he did is he kind of set events
in motion to create a global crisis
right to create like this giant global
calamity and he tells mark that is that
is happening in los angeles now he
doesn't tell marcus a global thing he
says like you know the the city where
i've done this is going to be in l.a
right it's los angeles where i've done
this millions need to die in order for
future billions to live right and so the
next thing you get is you get angstrom
levy like literally he's just like i
must have my revenge i've waited long
enough of course we know that like with
his escapades when he created all those
different invincibles or at least
brought them in from other realities to
destroy mark and initiated the
invincible war uh that ultimately he was
defeated and he was taken by the
technicians he's kind of enigmatic guys
that worked or the least that he worked
for and ultimately he was just kind of
cast aside they're like we don't need
you anymore they kicked him out of this
dimension and that was basically it and
so essentially he's kind of coming back
to earth uh angstrom levy's just the
plot the the plot device just won't go
away
the the villainy won't go away but mark
tries to radio cecil he finally gets a
hold of him tells him what's going on
arrives in los angeles finds one of the
bombs and then tells him get robot here
whoever so we can basically go through
and disarm all these now the funny thing
here is that on the surface it looks
like what robert kirkman is doing is the
same thing he did before and to a degree
kirkman does kind of have a history of
recycling plots when it comes to
invincible but not in the traditional
sense it's not as always a guy who
doesn't have ideas right kirkman is a
genius writer it's one of these things
where the idea serves the purpose of
going to a greater whole or it's a root
and that's what's happening here it's a
root that robot realizes very very
quickly this is not a bomb this is not
designed to basically detonate and to
disrupt you know the entirety of los
angeles instead this is basically a
device that's designed to influence and
activate other devices right most likely
to screw up the tectonic plates of los
angeles and so as they go through there
before anybody really has an
understanding of what's going on
suddenly all these tectonic plates start
disrupting and basically los angeles
experiences an earthquake right now this
is not new to the city of los angeles
right california has experienced a lot
of earthquakes over the years what's
significant about this is that dinosaurs
arrives on the scene in la and then is
ultimately met by mark and as the two of
them are going at it right dinosaurs
kind of rehashes this this sort of you
know the needs of the mini outweigh the
needs of the few right so the the
utilitarian argument that that we side
with right that we agree with here on
the channel where it's just like yeah
you know a few million people need to
die now for countless billions to
survive in the future right it's logical
anything short of that and you're just
being irrational and so it's one of
those interesting things because in the
midst of all that basically dinosaurus
reveals that if you were really that if
mark was really as smart as he makes
himself out to be he would realize this
is all a distraction that none of this
is designed to be the main thing right
that there's something much bigger going
on and when mark's like what like a
distraction from what then basically
like dinosaurs looks off into the
distance and when mark looks off in the
same direction he's like what are you
looking at and basically what dinosaurs
have done is basically destabilize what
looks like the entire country of
greenland or at least a huge chunk of it
and in turn is initiating what is in
effect a global catastrophe involving
the tidal waves he's basically sinking
the coastal cities and the argument
behind this is that most people settle
along coastal cities right i think it's
something like 80 of the world's
population lives along the coast i'm not
gonna you know take that number as an
absolute truth right i don't swear by it
i just i heard that number somewhere but
but regardless most people settle along
coastal cities by having so many people
there the idea of dinosaurs is to
essentially destabilize the way in which
people live and by focusing on the fact
that coastal cities are now under water
that's the future of climate change he's
basically fast tracking the effects of
climate change or at least simulating
the effects of climate change to
essentially jog people right to say fine
if you're not going to change of your
own volition if you're going to drag
your feet then i'm going to do what i
have to do right and that's just sink or
or cover these coastal cities and water
so you can see what your future will
look like not in a hundred years right
when it's just some distant thing in the
future that you don't really have to
worry about but when it's happening in
the here and now just millions and
millions of people are being killed by
dinosaurs and that's what kind of just
flabbergasts and blows the mind of mark
because as you would expect a giant
fight breaks out between the two of them
now again it's one of those things where
mark takes a stance of like dinosaurs is
a mass murderer dinosaurs takes a stance
of like i get where your anger's coming
from right like i did something outside
of your control basically there's
nothing mark could do to stop dinosaurs
and it's something that makes mark feel
weak right it makes it feel like he
can't do anything that's the perspective
dinosaurs has but understand what
dinosaurs is doing is the right thing
here right that as human beings we kind
of have this tendency to look at a look
at a problem and say well if the problem
is not here and now if we don't have to
face it here in this moment well the
problem doesn't exist you know and so we
won't worry about it until we actually
have to face it and if we're doing so if
we're talking about something like a
homework assignment right if we're
talking about something like an
assignment on the job right or something
along those lines that's easy to cope
with when you're talking about the the
ability for humanity to continue
existing that's a much bigger problem
right and so dinosaurs kind of looking
at humanity as a whole and saying
humanity is in an effect lazy right
humanity won't fix the problem until the
problem requires that it be fixed or
until being able to move forward uh
requires a fixing of the problem right
the ability to move forward is
impossible without that problem being
fixed then humanity will do nothing
about it right it is in the nature of
people to want the greatest reward for
the least amount of work possible where
you do have a few exceptions to that
rule that's most people right the
exceptions to the rule are people like
dinosaurs right people like mark or
something like that people who aren't
really sleepwalking through life and so
it's one of those things where it's
where it's intriguing because at the end
of the day dinosaurs he makes this
argument he's like i'm not doing this
because i'm looking to amass power i
don't want to push humanity to the brink
of extinction and wipe out 80 of the
world's population because that's really
what is happening here right killing
most people who exist along coastal
cities that's wiping out something like
80 of the world's population he's like
i'm doing this because i care because
it's about saving modern civilization
right by wiping out 80 of people it
takes society back down to twenty
percent now the funny thing about this
is that dinosaurs is assuming that
humanity would even learn from this in
the in the first place right one of the
other aspects of humanity is this people
don't care what you say as long as you
say it nicely that's how people that's
how people view the world now right so
you could walk up to a person and call
them everything but a child of god so
long as you do it in a way that sounds
nice and so at the end of the day
because what you have here is an
extremely violent action that comes from
a place of trying to achieve a
legitimate means people won't care
because the action overshadows the
message and so in the midst of all this
because of the fact that marx simply
won't give it up right because of the
fact that mark's like no like i'm not
tolerating this you know i trusted you
you told me that we were going to work
together you told me you were not going
to implement any more plans where you
are going to cause catastrophic loss of
life like you told me that we could work
together and because dinosaurs
vehemently believes that he's right at
the end of the day he overpowers mark
and is like there's only one thing to do
here right only one thing that can be
done and so in the rubble of this
collapsing building he overpowers mark
knocks him out and then kills him in
front of in front of everybody in front
of the world where the whole thing's
being streamed he rips his body in half
and throws it away and that's it as far
as the world is concerned mark is dead
right at that point mark wakes up in
total blackness right just wakes up in
just a complete and total landscape of
pure blackness he can't hear anything
and he can't see anything he can hear
himself i guess so that's basically it
but then he hears this kind of
disembodied voice that comes out of
nowhere now while that's going on
humanity is on the outside trying to
find some way to basically set the tide
back to where it's supposed to be right
to basically create this circumstance
where the waters recede from the coastal
regions i mean this would happen over
time humanity is just trying to get it
to happen faster
right the faster it happens the more
lives they can save is basically what's
going on right the more humanity can
continue to contribute to problems with
the environment and so what you end up
having is basically mark strapped up to
a bed and dinosaurs just kind of over
you know watching over him right and
it's one of these cool things where he
says if you've noticed and maybe it's
something that mark had never studied
before but that vulture might themselves
have the ability to fly and that what
this is done or how this is achieved is
through an impossibly complicated and
incredibly sensitive process that
happens in his ears in effect mark's
ears are his weakness and that's exactly
what dinosaurs targeted and it was a
pretty genius maneuver what dinosaurs
did here is he had to prove that he was
right he needed the world to see that he
was the dominant guy not so that he
could conquer the world but so that the
world would view his philosophies as
being right and so what he did is to
remove mark from the equation both so
mark could just kind of continue to
operate seemingly in in secret that what
he did is he went through a series of
processes trying to clone mark now part
of this seemed to be because he was
trying to find a way to duplicate mark
so that mark could basically have his
powers or something along those lines
those powers could be restored to him
but once mark showed back up with his
powers the fight broke out but a cloned
body had already been created albeit
imperfect that in the midst of this
fight when it looked like mark had been
knocked out what dinosaurs had actually
done was open a portal in that crumbling
building throw mark through it so mark
would land here and then in turn grab
the clone body and then rip it in half
so as far as the world was concerned
mark was dead when in reality it was a
trick by dinosaurs it's pretty genius
it's a pretty ingenious thing now of
course ancient levy also comes back and
then finds out mark's step doesn't
really matter tomorrow it's a thing
that's happening but it will become
important later on down the line the
thing about this though is that mark and
and dinosaurs actually get into this
really really interesting debate where
mark approaches things a little bit
different and he's like here's the
problem that you have dinosaurs right
what if everything you've done all the
work put towards fixing things what if
that's the exact opposite of what needs
to happen the coming climate crisis was
forcing humanity to rethink everything
right it had us considering new ways of
life new ways to find energy to survive
on this planet it was causing us to
reform to change our old ways to grow
and to adapt you think you've saved us
by taking the problem away by killing us
so that we don't harm the ecosystem so
that we don't harm the planet because
there are less of us you've just slowed
things down and you haven't fixed
anything and that is really the truth to
a degree of what what dinosaurs did he's
still right in his actions but at the
end of the day mark makes a very good
point here right it's like sheltering a
person from the dangers of the world
versus letting a person experience the
dangers of the world are they going to
get some bumps and bruises sure are they
going to get hurt yes are they going to
be pushed to their mental and emotional
limits absolutely are they going to come
out stronger if they survive it yes
right that's the nature of the world you
have to let people struggle you have to
let them go through these terrible
situations so they can build this
all-encompassing and universally
important thing called resilience and
that's what mark's message is to
dinosaurs you can't simply just remove
the problem from humanity and believe
that humanity will somehow enter an age
of utopia and everything will be okay
humanity has to fail people have to fail
they have to find some way to fix the
problem on their own otherwise they will
never learn anything right it's the
dinosaurs equivalent of thanos blinking
out half the life in the universe in
order to fix overpopulation and all that
kind of stuff and a lack of resources
right if humanity doesn't understand or
agree with the motivation for why it was
done nothing will be learned and so the
actions of thanos become a stopgap
measure because in 500 years the entire
universe's population is right back up
to where it was before right and so at
the end of the day dinosaurs brings mark
out right he's like okay fine right he
just basically allows more to wake up
and says like you're like i've set you
free mark and i can i can see that now i
can see that you're right right i can
see that humanity just has to be allowed
to fail right these actions of mine
despite the fact that they come from uh
from a place of positivity will not
teach humanity anything humanity is
going to have to undergo its course of
developing renewable energies and like
electric cars and stuff like that only
to find out that it's too late and
they're going to have to basically be
pushed to the brink of extinction and to
face complete and catastrophic
destruction of the human race and then
if they survive they'll take those
lessons going forward right but like
it's like what's happening here in the
real world right climate change in the
real world it's way too late it's been
too late
it's been too late for a long time at
this point humanity's just kind of
slowly walking to its own demise and
we've only got so long before you know
things just get really really bad but
there's no saving the day right it's
just too late here and so because of
that dinosaurs basically says there's
only one thing to be done here right
like for me like i get that it was wrong
to flood these cities but i thought i
was doing the right thing and in truth i
will not stop right i believe that i am
right i believe that i'm doing the right
thing but so long as i as i continue to
exist as i try to fix things improve
things somehow all that's gonna happen
is that seemingly things are going to
get worse and so there's only one option
here mark you need to do exactly what
you should have done in las vegas you
have to kill me and mark does mark kills
dinosaurs we don't see it happen it
happens off panel but literally mark
comes out covered in blood right so
basically he kills dinosaurs and that's
basically the end of it right and so at
that point you end up learning from
cecil that what's happened here is that
robot along with some of the best
scientific minds in the world have
essentially created kind of uh
artificial moons that will basically
have a synchronous orbit around the
world and basically balance the tides
out right is essentially what these are
going to be doing and then it'll it'll
last however long it needs to last until
they can effectively save the day and
then of course you switch over to the
home of marcan and adam eve adam eve of
course losing her mind because she
believed that what she saw was real mark
really was ripped in half mark was dead
of course mark shows up because
everything's cool you know all that kind
of cool stuff and the day saved and you
know everything is copacetic but then
you find out that adam he was pregnant
again right so that's kind of a cool
thing you know where mark's like i mean
i thought we were careful we were using
like condoms you know protection and
whatnot and she's like i don't know
maybe it's just it's the nature of just
being uh being a filter by right i mean
you know it's just it broke through
i have no idea but the important thing
and this this is probably the most
significant thing to come out of this
story is basically general thrack and
the reason why is because with freddie
mercury one of the things to keep in
mind is freddie mercury has been very
pissed off with most or at least with
some of the villager might race and the
reason why is because the vulture mites
are supposed to be here on this world
for the purpose of procreation right to
bring the numbers of the vulture might
race back up i mean sure there'll be a
hybrid between vulture mites and humans
but as we've seen over the course of the
invincible series that basically a human
vulture might hybrid is actually
stronger than either one by themselves
and so with everything that's going on
and the fact that general thrack had
discovered that some of his people just
are only procreating with one person
right they're following what what is an
effect the standard human uh concept of
marriage which is you find a person you
settle down with that person you form a
family you live the rest of your lives
together and then like you both die
right just kind of following that sort
of formulaic pattern that in turn it's
slowing the process right some of those
wheelchair mites are refusing to
procreate at all like they don't want to
have have any kind of kids at all and so
because of this he ends up basically
blaming nolan right that in reality it's
essentially the fault of nolan and so a
fight basically breaks out between the
two and all hell starts to break loose
now the crazy thing about that is that
in this conflict and in this battle
freddie mercury basically comes clean
and says like it's time that you
understand the truth nolan right like
like when noah's like why are you
attacking me right like what what's
going on he's like it's time that you
know the truth right it's how you
understand what's really going on and so
what he does is he just kind of reveals
the truth of what's happening right that
in the aftermath of the scourge virus
and the idea of the viltrumite race
basically falling apart experiencing
self-destruction and so on that that
general thrag had rose as the grand
region and the strongest of them all and
basically taking control he provided
order where order didn't exist anymore
and that in turn what he had done was
restructure the vulture might race so
that they were the most powerful right
but all this had been done following the
death of lord argol right remember lord
argol had basically been killed off as
the last remaining leader of the vulture
might race and his family line his
descendants were basically believed to
have been killed but when freddie
mercury learned that nolan and mark were
the rightful heirs to the throne of
viltrum he panicked and he killed
seemingly anybody who knew what was
going on and so in turn he swore that
anybody who was a descendant of of argol
would be killed off and that he would
maintain his control over the vulture my
race because it was only by his
leadership that the vulture might race
basically continue to exist right nolan
doesn't care he's like i don't care like
i don't want to lead the wheelchair
might race i have no interest in that
i've got my wife i got my kids i want my
life here i want to be left the hell
alone and that's it but from the stance
of freddie mercury it's no so long as
you exist you and your future
descendants will be a threat to my reign
because while you don't care and mark
doesn't care maybe your grandson will or
maybe your great-great-grandson will
maybe any one of the future heirs that
come from you guys will care so long as
i let you live i will have to worry
about my reign being challenged and it
will be done legally right they will
have every right to claim control of the
throne and there'll be nothing that i
can do and so in the midst of this fight
where freddie mercury is getting the
upper hand on nolan suddenly he's
stopped right where he's about to kill
this guy he's basically stopped and he's
stopped by the other members of the
vulture might race who show up here and
they're like explain yourself what's
going on and that's when he tries to try
to pass this off that what nolan was
doing was trying to assassinate him
right he was assassination attempt he's
trying to take out you know freddie
mercury so that no one could seize
control the filter might rachel himself
you know conquer everything all that
kind of stuff and one of them basically
picks up you found the air of argol
right that's who this guy is this guy
nolan is the is the the rightful heir of
the viltrumide empire and the response
of freddie mercury is and he's weak look
at him like absolutely pummeled this guy
right like strength is what made our
race great and the response of the
vulture of wiltermites is no we followed
lord argol because of his wisdom because
he led us to do and to accomplish great
things we followed you because you were
the strongest of us and at that time we
needed a person of strength but we don't
need a person of strength we need a
person who's wise that's not you and
they basically go to attack him and
actually just start beating him to death
and then ultimately no one tells him to
stand down and it's like no and at that
point they all bend the knee that as it
stands right now nolan is being
recognized as the rightful ruler of the
viltrumite race he is the heir to the
throne and he is now the viltrumite king
and so taking uh taking a position and
and really kind of stepping into it and
talking to the viltromites and
essentially saying i know this is all
kind of weird right this is all kind of
a kind of a strange time i'm going to
make this quick embrace what it means to
live on earth embrace the idea of having
a family i know you guys usually at
least in years past you guys as
wheelchair might you didn't really
settle down with any one particular
person right it was just indiscriminate
procreation with however many people you
wanted to but that's not how things work
here right the way that you're
experiencing this in the sense that you
find a partner and you settle down with
that partner and you pop out some kids
and you live your life together with
that partner right how everybody does it
you know that is that's how things get
done here right so embrace that step
into it that's not something that should
be shunned right live your life and
enjoy the life that you've created with
humanity and it's kind of celebrated
they're like yeah mark thinks it's weird
right to be here and watch all this
unfold but it's basically celebrated and
so following that you basically
transition back to mark talking with
adam eve and the reality is like he kind
of dumps the information about his dad
basically being the one to leave the
villager might race now then mark is
essentially a prince or whatever you
would call a prince as the son of an
emperor right so i don't know exactly
what that name would be right just
emperor in waiting i don't really know
but at the end of it all there is a part
of mark that questions the legitimacy of
his dad right it's one of those kind of
it's one of those interesting things
that even after everything that's
happened mark asked the question part of
me thinks was it some kind of evil
genius right was it all some plan that
he had orchestrated right that knowing
all this would happen right instigating
the the viltrumite war and all that kind
of stuff and knowing that vulture might
race because of the fact that humans and
viltromites are almost identical in
terms of dna that pushing their race to
the brink of extinction would lead them
here and basically consolidate them down
into one place and then essentially
organize everything in such a way to
where he'd be able to rise up is
basically the the legitimate leader of
the villager might race itself and then
basically become its ruler is that
really what he was shooting for of
course we know that's that's not the
case right that's not really what was
going on or at least it doesn't seem to
be but the important thing is that at
the end of the day mark's like it's cool
right i mean it's just kind of a
question that i had some kind of a
thought that i was wondering but because
of the fact that adam eve and mark are
expecting another kid they're like let's
do this the right way all right let's do
let's do it the way that we're supposed
to be doing right like we we're having a
child right we are doing what humanity's
been doing since the dawn of modern man
so i guess that's cool and it's like
let's do this the right way so because
of the fact that mark i mean mark's
broke right that's one thing to keep in
mind mark doesn't have money right i
mean he doesn't really i mean i guess he
does because he's got like the the whole
organization thing but she ends up
basically popping the question right as
one of the very rare turns uh that you
normally never see that adam eve is
actually the one that asks mark to marry
her as opposed to the other way around
right she literally materializes a ring
out of nowhere and it was like it's the
ring i always wanted so i figured i
might as well just make it myself and
she's like will you marry me and in the
end mark's like yeah absolutely i will
right so of course we get to avoid that
future where mark and adam eve just
never really get together and she just
ends up being miserable for the rest of
her life but mark and adam even getting
married so it's cool but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace